My first point, it's a shadow of APL. My second point, though, is that it's still pretty great. You know, as far as Python goes, if you program in NumPy, your Python code is faster. NumPy is faster than Python because at the end of the day, episode 213, recorded on December 10th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we discuss NumPy, summed area tables, and more. You know, you mentioned in the last episode that you've been doing more and more Python. And I also have been doing more and more Python the past six to eight months. And I don't remember. I think we may have talked a little bit in a previous prior episode about sort of my search for understanding about what is Pythonic.
我的第一个观点是，它是 APL 的影子。但我的第二个观点是，它仍然非常棒。你知道，就 Python 而言，如果你用 NumPy 编程，你的 Python 代码会更快。NumPy 比 Python 快，因为归根结底，第 213 集，录制于 2024 年 12 月 10 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起讨论 NumPy、求和面积表等等。你知道，你在上一集中提到你一直在做越来越多的 Python 开发。在过去的六到八个月里，我也一直在做越来越多的 Python 开发。我不记得了。我想我们可能在之前的一集中讨论过我对于什么是“Pythonic”（符合 Python 风格）的探索。
And I sort of feel like I've now grasped Pythonic. I now have a sense of what it is. But what I want to talk about before we get into this algorithm is NumPy. And I want to get your thoughts on what do you think of NumPy? Because for me, learning NumPy coming from C++ has been at times, it has been both refreshing and frustrating. And I wonder if you've had a similar experience. Sorry, learning Python or learning NumPy? Learning NumPy specifically. So let's time box this to two minutes so that I don't go on forever here. My first comment.
我感觉我现在已经掌握了“Pythonic”。我现在对它有了一些了解。但在我们进入这个算法之前，我想谈谈 NumPy。我想听听你对 NumPy 的看法？因为对我来说，从 C++ 转过来学习 NumPy，有时既让人耳目一新，又让人感到沮丧。我想知道你是否有类似的经历。抱歉，是学习 Python 还是学习 NumPy？专门学习 NumPy。所以让我们把时间限制在两分钟内，这样我就不会在这里没完没了地说了。我的第一个评论。
Oh, and we should say what NumPy is. NumPy is the number one popular library probably in the world because Python is one of the most popular languages. First, if not first, second. And it is an array library, which means that you've got your NP, which is typically you go import numpy as NP. NP.array gives you access to a multi-dimensional array where you can do APL, array language-like things, with these arrays, such as they're called different things in different languages,
哦，我们应该说明一下什么是 NumPy。NumPy 可能是世界上最受欢迎的库，因为 Python 是最流行的语言之一。如果不是第一，也是第二。它是一个数组库，这意味着你有你的 NP，通常你会写 import numpy as NP。NP.array 让你能够访问多维数组，你可以用这些数组做类似 APL（数组语言）的事情，比如它们在不同的语言中被称为不同的东西，
scalar or pervasive operations. So you can for scalar operations, like plus times minus, you don't need to map these operations, the number of maps over the dimensions of your array. So like, I love to show the Haskell example, where if you have a list of lists, and you want to add one to every number in that list, you have to go map map of plus one over your list with some parentheses in there in order to get that to work. Whereas in a NumPy, you just go plus one. And it automatically, using a technique called broadcasting, which is just what they call,
标量或普遍操作。所以对于标量操作，比如加、乘、减，你不需要映射这些操作，不需要在数组的维度上进行映射。就像我喜欢展示的 Haskell 例子，如果你有一个列表的列表，并且你想给列表中的每个数字加一，你必须在你的列表上使用 map map 加一，并加上一些括号才能让它工作。而在 NumPy 中，你只需要加一。它会自动使用一种称为广播（broadcasting）的技术，这正是他们所称的，
it's their form of rank polymorphism. And that's just a, rank polymorphism is just a fancy word for being able to apply these operations to arrays of different ranks. So integers or scalars have rank zero. Lists have rank one. Matrices or tables, however you want to call them, they have rank two.
这是他们的一种秩多态性（rank polymorphism）。秩多态性只是一个花哨的词，意思是能够将这些操作应用于不同秩的数组。所以整数或标量是零秩。列表是一秩。矩阵或表格，无论你怎么称呼它们，它们是二秩。
A cube has rank three. And it goes all the way up. I think there's a limit in NumPy. I don't know what it is. I think in APL or J, I think the limit was 63 dimensions at one point, which you don't typically end up doing stuff with 63 dimensions. But, you know, when you're designing a end up doing stuff with 63 dimensions. But you know, when you're designing a language, there's no reason to really limit it if you can design
立方体是三秩。它一直往上增加。我想 NumPy 中有一个限制。我不知道是多少。我想在 APL 或 J 中，曾经有一个 63 个维度的限制，你通常不会用 63 个维度来做事情。但是，你知道，当你设计一种语言时，如果你能设计得通用，就没有理由真正限制它。
it generically. Anyways, that's what NumPy is. What are my thoughts and feelings about it? It is a shadow of the power of array languages. NumPy is basically just an APL implemented in Python. I was about to say poorly implemented. I don't want to say poorly. It's just like whenL implemented in Python. I was about to say poorly implemented. I don't want to say poorly. It's just like when you're in a language where all functions are words and you have operator overloading, but only to a certain extent,
无论如何，这就是 NumPy。我对它有什么想法和感受？它是数组语言力量的影子。NumPy 基本上只是用 Python 实现的 APL。我刚才想说实现得很差。我不想说差。这就像当你处于一种所有函数都是单词并且你有运算符重载的语言中时，但只在一定程度上，
it's what you end up with. You can't do a ton better in Python than NumPy, but you lose a lot of the elegance and power of a... Well, but you don't get composition, right? Because everything is sort of eager. You can't really do like lazy composition of things fusion is what we should say there you don't get the the fusion of operations so there is um there are libraries uh out there that try to do this kind of stuff but um numpy does not so and that also a lot of the array languages as well do not fuse, which is one of the critiques
这就是你最终得到的结果。在 Python 中，你无法比 NumPy 做得更好，但你失去了很多优雅和力量……嗯，但你没有得到组合，对吧？因为一切都是急切的（eager）。你不能真正做到像懒惰组合（lazy composition）那样的融合，我们应该说的是融合（fusion），你没有得到操作的融合。所以有一些库试图做这种事情，但 NumPy 没有。而且很多数组语言也不进行融合，这是对 NumPy 和数组语言的批评之一，
of both NumPy and array languages is whenever you do plus one times two, and then you wrap that all in a summation, that's three different operations. Two, one addition, one multiplication, and one reduction. And a lot of the times that ends up in creating whole new matrices. So like you can imagine that instead of doing some in-place transform and c++ i'm doing like a copy if before each of those and then like then doing my transform and like i very sadly we don't we've already had this conversation we mix up the underscore copy versions like the semantics of some of our algorithms like sort uh is in place yeah um
每当你做加一乘二，然后把所有这些包装在一个求和中时，那是三个不同的操作。一次加法，一次乘法，一次归约。很多时候，这最终会创建全新的矩阵。所以你可以想象，与其在 C++ 中进行某种原地转换，我是在每次转换之前进行复制，然后进行转换。我很遗憾我们已经进行过这次对话了，我们混淆了下划线复制版本，比如我们一些算法的语义，比如 sort 是原地操作，是的，
by default but doesn't give you a set of output iterators. Anyways, we've already had that conversation. My first point, it's a shadow of APL. My second point though, is that it's still pretty great. You know, as far as Python goes, if you program in NumPy, your Python code is faster. NumPy is faster than Python because at the end of the day, NumPy is implemented in C and C is faster than Python. So a lot of this stuff, maybe paradoxically or unergonomically, if you take a list in Python, convert it to a NumPy array and then do your operations on that NumPy array and
默认情况下，但不给你一组输出迭代器。无论如何，我们已经进行过那次对话了。我的第一个观点，它是 APL 的影子。我的第二个观点是，它仍然非常棒。你知道，就 Python 而言，如果你用 NumPy 编程，你的 Python 代码会更快。NumPy 比 Python 快，因为归根结底，NumPy 是用 C 实现的，而 C 比 Python 快。所以很多这些东西，也许是矛盾的或不符合人体工程学的，如果你在 Python 中取一个列表，把它转换成 NumPy 数组，然后对那个 NumPy 数组进行操作，
then convert it back to a Python list, your code's going to be like, I don't know if it's an order of magnitude faster, but it's definitely a multiple faster than your Python lists, which means that like, if you're looking for performant Python code, become a NumPy expert. Even if you're not doing scientific compute, it's still a great library to do these kinds of, you know, basic generic programming operations with. And there's also, there's also this JIT compiler Numba, which can take Python code and JIT compile it down to native code. And in particular, Numba is NumPy aware. So it can take your NumPy code and turn it into code that is going to be, in a lot of cases, as fast as if you'd written something in C. So there's one particular
然后再把它转换回 Python 列表，你的代码会，我不知道是不是快了一个数量级，但肯定比你的 Python 列表快了好几倍，这意味着，如果你在寻找高性能的 Python 代码，那就成为 NumPy 专家。即使你不是在做科学计算，它仍然是一个很好的库，可以用来做这些基本的通用编程操作。而且还有一个 JIT 编译器 Numba，它可以获取 Python 代码并将其 JIT 编译为原生代码。特别是，Numba 是 NumPy 感知的。所以它可以获取你的 NumPy 代码并将其转换为在很多情况下和你用 C 编写的一样快的代码。所以有一个特别的
thing in NumPy that there's a bunch of like little quirks that I think have just been like stylistic differences between C++ and Python that I've sort of adapted to. But there's one thing that it really is a difference in approach that still bothers me. And that is around like userdefined reductions and scans. So let's say that you wanted to do just a plus reduction, a reduction with just operator plus on an array of ints. You can just do np.sum, right? Yes. And if you want to do a scan, you can do np.cumsum,
NumPy 中的东西，有一堆小怪癖，我认为这只是 C++ 和 Python 之间的风格差异，我已经适应了。但有一件事确实是方法上的差异，仍然困扰着我。那就是关于用户定义的归约（reductions）和扫描（scans）。假设你想做一个加法归约，一个只用加法运算符对整数数组进行的归约。你只需要做 np.sum，对吧？是的。如果你想做一个扫描，你可以做 np.cumsum，
or there's a longer version spelled cumulative sum. But what if you want to have your own, you want to provide your own operator? Like if you want to do something like a max reduction, there's, okay, there's np.max, but maybe you want to write like your own, like, you know, quirky, you know, operator, like, how would you do it? So there are two different ways. Technically, all of the equivalents of higher order functions like reduce, scan, outer product, which I believe outer product is called outer. And as you mentioned, well, actually, I think the generic version of cumulative sum or cum sum is called accumulate, which I've highlighted in several talks and lightning talks, because I think it's when I first discovered that I was like, Are you kidding me? Our reduction in C++ is what they call a scan in Python.
或者有一个拼写为 cumulative sum 的更长版本。但如果你想拥有自己的运算符呢？比如如果你想做类似最大值归约的事情，好吧，有 np.max，但也许你想写你自己的，你知道，古怪的运算符，你会怎么做？所以有两种不同的方法。从技术上讲，所有类似高阶函数的东西，如 reduce、scan、外积（outer product），我相信外积被称为 outer。正如你提到的，实际上，我认为 cumulative sum 或 cum sum 的通用版本被称为 accumulate，我在几次演讲和闪电演讲中都强调过它，因为当我第一次发现它时，我就想，你在开玩笑吗？我们在 C++ 中的归约在 Python 中被称为扫描。
Anyways, so you you all of these higher order functions, I think they have some mechanism where they have binary operations where you can call those higher order functions as methods, which are just manually implemented. So if you want to call, it makes more sense when you don't have basically convenience names. So sum is what they call a plus reduction. But if you want to do an outer product on like the max binary operation, there's something where you go like operation dot max, and then you can call as a method dot outer. And that is the way you do an outer product on a implemented binary operation that NumPy provides for you. So that's probably not the answer you're looking for. That's answer number one, though. The second answer is if you want some binary operation that is not provided
无论如何，所以你所有的这些高阶函数，我认为它们有一些机制，它们有二元操作，你可以将这些高阶函数作为方法调用，这些方法只是手动实现的。所以如果你想调用它，当你没有基本的便利名称时，它更有意义。所以 sum 是他们所谓的加法归约。但如果你想在 max 二元操作上做外积，有一些东西你可以写 operation.max，然后你可以作为方法调用 .outer。这就是你在 NumPy 为你提供的已实现二元操作上做外积的方法。所以这可能不是你在寻找的答案。不过这是第一个答案。第二个答案是，如果你想要一些 NumPy 没有提供的二元操作，
by NumPy, and it's some bespoke thing, which is a, you know, whatever, a couple of binary operations combined the way that i have done it in the past is you need to build up that binary operation typically in the form of a lambda you then pass that lambda to this function called from pi funk that i think numpy performs and it basically uh is a function that will take an arbitrary binary expression and then have you you're then able to pass that to whatever like higher order function you want so it's like you go numpy dot from py funk you pass it your your arbitrary binary expression and then you call like dot order or something i can't remember the exact order but it involves like building up a custom lambda
而且是一些定制的东西，你知道，无论是什么，几个二元操作结合在一起，我过去的做法是，你需要构建那个二元操作，通常以 lambda 的形式，然后你把那个 lambda 传递给这个叫做 frompyfunc 的函数，我想 NumPy 执行它，它基本上是一个函数，它会接受一个任意的二元表达式，然后你就可以把它传递给任何你想要的高阶函数。所以就像你写 numpy.frompyfunc，你传递你的任意二元表达式，然后你调用类似 .outer 的东西，我不记得确切的顺序了，但它涉及构建一个自定义 lambda，
passing it to this from pyfunk and then like using that which is coming from like c++ where you just have generic algorithms that you can pass generic operations it is it's painful it's like taking a yeah and so part of that so in numpy there's this notion of a universal function which is what from pyfunk gives you. And a universal function is like a scalar function that NumPy transforms or vectorizes into something that can be applied to arrays. And it's cool because
把它传递给这个 frompyfunc，然后像那样使用它。这就像来自 C++，在那里你只是有通用的算法，你可以传递通用的操作，这很痛苦。这就像……是的，所以其中的一部分是，在 NumPy 中，有这种通用函数（universal function）的概念，这就是 frompyfunc 给你的。而通用函数就像一个标量函数，NumPy 将其转换或向量化为可以应用于数组的东西。这很酷，因为
these scalar functions they get they use the NumPy broadcasting rules. And so the broadcasting rules are like what happens if you do, like, if you call something with a matrix and a vector,
这些标量函数，它们使用 NumPy 的广播规则。所以广播规则就像如果你这样做，比如，如果你用矩阵和向量调用某些东西，
like a 2D array and a 1D array, how does that work? And there's this complex set of rules that's, I think, fairly intuitive for how this broadcasting works for different shapes of things so that you don't necessarily have to have all the things be the same shape.
比如 2D 数组和 1D 数组，它是如何工作的？有一套复杂的规则，我认为对于这种广播如何适用于不同形状的东西来说是相当直观的，这样你就不一定非要让所有东西的形状都相同。
And one of the reasons why they have these universal functions for writing your own element-wise operations is because writing it as a function and then passing it to this decorator, this vectorized decorator, gives you more
他们有这些用于编写你自己的逐元素操作的通用函数的原因之一是，将其编写为一个函数，然后将其传递给这个装饰器，这个向量化装饰器，会给你带来更多
efficient code than you would get if you just wrote a for loop that iterated through the entire like array and then did your thing manually so basically it's like to avoid doing like raw loops but the thing that i just don't understand is why why can't we just have the sum function take another operator that's you know know, a function or, you know, like a lambda, and then under the hood, it can call like the vectorize on it. Like, why is it that I have to go in, I have to go and do like the frompy func, something like that.
高效的代码，比你只是写一个遍历整个数组然后手动做你的事情的 for 循环要好。所以基本上，这就像是为了避免做原始循环。但我只是不明白为什么，为什么我们不能直接让 sum 函数接受另一个运算符，你知道，一个函数，或者一个 lambda，然后在底层，它可以调用类似 vectorize 的东西。为什么我必须进去，我必须去做类似 frompyfunc 的事情，类似那样。
And then I have to call like.outer,.reduce or whatever on it. Like, it just feels very odd. I would prefer to do the C++ thing where it's like, oh, I want to do a reduction. Like I can just call dot sum and it'll just do it with like, you know, operator plus. But if I want to have my own operator, I can just call sum my array comma the function I want to call it on. Like that just seems so much more intuitive to me. And it just is a little bit mind blowing to me that that's not a thing. And I think it just, it just illustrates the difference in, in approaches. Sorry, wait, I didn't understand the, you said you want dot sum to take a custom operation or did you mean to say like dot,
然后我必须在它上面调用类似 .outer、.reduce 之类的东西。这感觉非常奇怪。我更喜欢做 C++ 的事情，就像，哦，我想做一个归约。我可以只调用 .sum，它就会用运算符加号来做。但如果我想拥有我自己的运算符，我可以只调用 sum 我的数组，逗号我想要调用的函数。这对我来说似乎直观多了。这让我有点震惊，这不是一个东西。我认为这只是说明了方法上的差异。抱歉，等等，我不明白，你说你想要 .sum 接受一个自定义操作，还是你的意思是说类似 .reduce？因为像 .sum。不，就像，是的，我想要 .sum 能够接受一个自定义操作。我不想做这个事情。操作做什么？嗯，不，不，不。操作就像你的归约操作。嗯，所以我很困惑。为什么你想要，因为 sum 对我来说就像是硬编码为加法归约。所以为什么你想要能够自定义加法？好吧。也许 NumPy 应该有一个顶层的东西叫做 reduce。
dot reduce? Cause like dot sum. No, like, yeah, I want like dot sum to, to, to be able to take a custom operation. I don't want to do this thing. Like what, what does the operation do? Uh, no, no, no. The operation would just be like your reduction operation. Well, so I'm confused. Why do you want to, like, because sum to me is like hard-coded to plus reduce. So why do you want to be able to customize the plus? Okay. Maybe then NumPy should have a top-level thing called like reduce.
我想我想要表达的奇怪之处在于，如果我用运算符加号做求和，我调用一个顶层算法。但如果我想做我自己的自定义归约，我必须创建我的运算符，然后我不把我的运算符传递给某个算法，我做的是在它上面调用 .reduce 方法，这就像我不想要的差异。我想要的是一个统一的 API，有一个叫做 numpy.reduce 的东西。我可以调用它，你知道，数组。如果我不带运算符调用它，它隐式地使用加号，或者也许我们决定我们不想有隐式的东西。它应该总是接受一个运算符。但对我来说，这更自然。它就像一个顶层函数，就像 reduce 这样的东西，就像运算符，而不是它现在的样子，它就像运算符 .reduce 的东西。我不知道足够多的关于 Python 和 NumPy 实现的知识，不知道是否有任何具体原因，因为我同意。
I guess the thing that I'm getting at that's odd is if I'm doing a sum with like operator operator plus i call a top level algorithm thing but if i want to do my own custom reduction i have to create my operator and then i don't pass my operator to some algorithm what i do is i call the dot reduce method on on it and that is like a difference that i don't want what i want is i want like a unified API where there's like, there's a thing called like numpy.reduce. And I can call it with, you know, array. And if I call it with no operator, it implicitly uses plus, or maybe we decide that we don't want to have implicit things. It should always take an operator. But to me, that's just more natural. It's just to have it be like a top level function that's like reduce like thing like operator instead of what it is right now is it's like it's like operator dot reduce of the thing. I don't know enough about the Python and NumPy implementation to know if there's any specific reason, because I agree.
是的，我怀疑有。这是一个更符合人体工程学的 API，就像每种语言，我不应该说每种，很多语言，包括函数式语言、C++ 等，高阶函数的工作方式是你传递给它作为自定义行为的操作，你不会构建一些东西，然后有一组预先实现的高阶东西，然后你再去调用那个方法。但我的猜测是他们那样做是有原因的，它与……我想也是。是的，但我完全同意。
Yeah, I suspect there is. It is a more ergonomic api like every language i shouldn't say every a lot of languages including functional languages c++ etc the way higher order functions work is you pass it the the operation as custom behavior you don't build up some thing and then have like a pre-implemented set of higher order things that you'd then go, you know, dot and then call that method. But my guess is there's a reason that they do that and it has to do with. I think so too. Yeah, but I'm totally on board.
我同意 reduce 的事情。绝对同意。如果可能的话。我要利用剩下的时间和你谈谈我一直在摆弄的一个非常酷的算法，这是我第一次被提出的问题，这个算法可以用于求和面积表。你以前听说过求和面积表吗？没有，只是从你发给我的消息中听说过，但我之后从来没有谷歌过它。我只是想象在某个时候你会通过谈话或播客向我解释这一点。是的。所以求和面积表的想法——所以一个部分和，你取一个数组，你得到直到数组末尾的所有部分和。求和面积表就像那样，但只是在 2D 中。以及图像转换，基本上你对每一行做部分和，然后你对每一列做部分和，这样最后一个元素，你知道，在第 M 行和第 M 列中的元素，就像右下角，如果你把它想象成一张图像，就像图像的右下角，那个最后一个元素将拥有整个东西的面积。这有意义吗？是的，完全有意义。我打开了 BQM pad，我已经有了我的 5x5 的 1 矩阵，你想让我分享这个吗？我的意思是，我可以走一遍。然后我会停止分享。别担心，我们不会让听众太失望的。所以我们有我们的 5x5 的 1 矩阵，这是 5 个字符，我们用两个字符加号和一个反斜杠做我们的加法扫描，然后我们想在做完这个之后做转置，天哪，你得喜欢 under，然后你想做同样的事情，嗯，你得喜欢 under。然后你想
I agree with the reduce thing. Definitely. If it was possible. I'm going to use the remaining time to talk to you about a very cool algorithm that I've been messing around with, which is the problem that I first was presented that this algorithm can be used for is a summed area table. Have you heard of summed area tables before? No, only from the messages that you sent me, but I never Googled it afterwards. I just imagined at some point you would be explaining this to me either via talk or via podcast. Yeah. So the idea with a summed area table – so a partial sum, you take an array and you get all the partial sums up until the end of the array. A summed area table is like that but just in like 2D. and image transformations where basically you do a partial sum for each row and then you do a partial sum for each column such that the last element, you know, the element in like the M in
做同样的事情。然后你就完成了。天哪，那真是太美了，伙计们。那真是太美了，伙计们。你知道，Connor，你刚才写的东西最美妙的地方在于，你甚至没有意识到，你已经完成了这个算法的技巧，这对于在 GPU 上高效实现它是必不可少的，那就是转置。因为让我们想想我们如何在 GPU 上做这个。所以这里有两个不同的扫描。所以首先，我们要扫描行。好的，所以我们要做的第一件事是，让我们假设行在我们的矩阵中是连续的。所以首先，我们要去扫描所有的行。所以让我们假设我们如何在 GPU 上做这个
row and column, like the bottom right, if you think about it as an image, like the bottom right of the image, that that last element will have the area of the entire thing. Does that make sense? Yes, it makes exact sense. I've got BQM pad open, I've already got my five by five matrix of ones, do you want me to share this? I mean, I can walk. And then I'll stop sharing. Don't worry, we're not going to lose the listener too bad. so we've got our our five by five matrix of ones which is five characters and we do our plus scan with two characters plus and then a backslash and then we want to after doing this we want to do under transpose god you got to love under and then you want to do the same thing um and you got to love under. And then you want to
是每个线程或也许每个线程块将加载一行，这在内存中是连续的，然后它将扫描那一行。所以它将加载一块连续的内存。这在性能方面很好。然后它将扫描它，然后它将写入它。但是然后，好的，我们做什么？所以现在我们必须扫描列。
do the same thing. And then you're done. God, that is that is gorgeous, folks. That's gorgeous, folks. You know, what's what's so beautiful about what you've just written, Connor, is that the without even realizing it, you have done the the trick to this algorithm that is essential for implementing it performantly on a GPU, which is the transpose. Because let's think about how we would do this on a GPU. So there's two different scans here. So first, we're going to scan the rows. Okay, so what we're going to do is first, we're going to, let's assume that like the rows are contiguous in our matrix. So first, we're going to go and scan all the rows. So let's assume that how we're going to do this in GPU
列不是连续的。而且我们已经把行加载到了这个线程块中。所以现在我们必须做的是，我们必须对列进行跨步加载，这将效率低得多，因为我们基本上是从连续数组中的一堆不同位置收集，因为它将是一个跨步加载。所以我们可以做的是，我们加载每一行，我们扫描每一行，然后这是假设这不是原地操作，而是我们正在写入一个新的输出。所以与其存储在原始位置，我们做的是我们做一个
is that each thread or maybe each thread block will load one row, which is contiguous in memory, and then it is going to scan that row. And so it's going to load a contiguous chunk of memory. That's good performance-wise. Then it's going to scan it, and then it's going to write it. But then, okay, what do we do? So now we have to scan the columns.
转置。我们存储转置后的行。我们这样做的原因是，我们将进行第二次传递。在第二次传递中，我们将对列进行扫描。但因为我们已经转置了数据，即使列最初在内存中不是连续的，因为转置，当我们进行第二次传递时，列现在在内存中是连续的。所以我们可以再次做快速的事情。如果我们用两个不同的内核来做这个，我们最终得到的是在第一个内核中，我们有加载行，做连续的内存加载，就像对于线程块，整个线程块加载一块连续的内存，然后它做扫描，然后它做分散存储。所以，
The columns aren't contiguous. And also, we've loaded in the row to this thread block. And so now what we would have to do is we'd have to do a strided load of the columns, which is going to be a lot less efficient because we'd basically be gathering from a bunch of different locations in our contiguous array because it's going to be a strided load. And so what we can do instead is we load each row, we scan each row, and then this is assuming that this is not in place, but that we're writing to a new output. So then instead of storing in the original locations, what we do is we do a
它做转置存储。现在，写入非连续内存，像那样对内存进行跨步写入，是的，它不如做跨步存储有效，但在 GPU 上存储总是比加载便宜得多，因为存储，你可以异步进行。我不必等待它。所以我做这个存储，然后这个内核结束，然后我开始下一个内核，它将加载那些列。我之所以在两个内核中做这个，是因为在那第一次分散存储之后，我必须有一个全局屏障。我必须让每个人都等到那些存储完成并传播。而且用第二次传递来做这件事更容易。在第二个内核中，我加载最初是行的内存位置。
transpose. We store the rows transposed. And the reason we do this is that we're then going to do a second pass. And in the second pass, we're going to do the scan of the columns. But because we've transposed the data, even though the columns originally were not contiguous in memory, because of the transpose, when we do the second pass, the columns are now contiguous in memory. And so we can again do the fast thing. And if we do this with two different kernels, what we end up is in the first kernel, we have load rows do contiguous like load of memory, like for the thread block, the entire thread block loads a contiguous chunk of memory, then it does the scan, and then it does a scatter store. So,
所以，这次我从输出中加载，这是我存储这些临时变量的地方。我加载转置后的数据。所以，现在我正在加载列。然后我扫描那些列。然后我再次做转置存储，它取消了矩阵的转置，给了我们正确的结果。我认为这是一个非常酷的算法。让我非常兴奋的是，第一，这是一个算法的例子，我认为最优情况可能是一个两遍算法。有些人向我指出，有另一种方法，你不会
it does the transposed store. Now, that writing to non-contiguous memory, doing a strided write to memory like that, yes, it's not as efficient as doing a strided store, but stores are always substantially cheaper than loads on a GPU because the store, you can do it asynchronously. I don't have to wait for it. So I do this store and then this kernel ends and then I start the next kernel, which is going to load those columns. And the reason that I do this in two kernels is because I have to have a global barrier after that first scatter store. I've got to have everybody wait until those stores are done and are propagated. And it's just easier to do that with a second pass. And in the second kernel, I load the memory locations that were originally the rows.
对整个列或整个行进行扫描。嗯，我们一会儿会讲到。但我会说这个。我刚才描述的这个算法的两遍版本，我认为是一个相当优雅的算法，通常当我看到多遍 GPU 算法时，我会想，我必须捏住鼻子。我会想，我更喜欢在单遍中做这个。但我认为这个的两遍版本太优雅了。但我正在和 Bradley Dice 谈论这个，我想是你以前在 Rapids 团队的同事之一。Bradley 说，哦，这就像一个多维扫描。我当时想，这很有趣。我没有那样想过。但他是对的。这就像一个多维扫描。这可以推广到多维。
So, I load from the output this time, which is where I've stored these temporaries. And I load the transposed data. So, now I'm loading columns. And then I scan those columns. And then I do a transpose store again, which untransposes the matrix, giving us the correct result. And I think this is a very cool algorithm. The thing that got me very excited about this was, one, this is an example of an algorithm where I think that the optimal case might be a two-pass algorithm. Some people have pointed out to me that there's another approach where you don't
但随后他指出了另一件有趣的事情。在扫描中，并行扫描算法，我们实现了这个叫做解耦回溯（decoupled lookback）的东西，你有这个依赖图，你知道，如果我是第 n 块数据，我依赖于 0 到 n-1 块数据。那个依赖链对于 1D 情况来说相当不——相当无聊。但 Bradley 指出，对于 2D 情况，它有这种波前属性，就像如果我在 n, m，我依赖于从 0, 0 到我的块 n, m 的所有块的图。他指出，哦，这听起来一旦你进入多维扫描，这听起来它有更多有趣的依赖关系。就像它有这种依赖图，也许这是你想要显式拥有依赖图的东西，
do a scan of the entire column or the entire own column. Well, we'll get there in a second. But I'll say this. The two-pass version of this algorithm that I just described, I think, is quite an elegant algorithm, which is usually when I look at multi-pass GPU algorithms, I'm like, I have to hold my nose. I'm like, I would prefer to do this in a single pass. But I think the two pass version of this one is so elegant. But I was talking with Bradley Dice, I think one of your former co-workers on the Rapids team about this. And Bradley said like, oh, this is like a multidimensional scan. And I was like, that's interesting. I hadn't thought about it like that. But he's right. It's like a multidimensional scan. This can be generalized to multidimensions.
特别是在你进入多个维度时。我觉得这非常有趣。它让我想起了一些——有一些线性代数算法有类似的依赖集。我想也许像 Jacobi 内核。但我还没有机会真正研究那部分，以及这种直觉，即这只是一个多维扫描，并且它有这种更有趣的
But then he pointed out something else interesting. In the scan, the parallel scan algorithm, which we implement this thing called decoupled lookback, you have this dependency graph where you, you know, if I'm the nth chunk of data, I depend on the 0 to n minus 1 chunks of data. And that dependency chain is like pretty non – it's pretty boring for the 1D case. But Bradley pointed out that for the 2D case, it's got this like wavefront property that like Like if I'm like at like n, m, I depend on like this graph of all of the chunks that are from 0, 0 up to my chunk in m. And he pointed out that, oh, this sounds like once you go to the multidimensional scan, this sounds like it's got a lot more interesting dependencies. Like it's got this sort of dependency graph, and maybe this is something where you want to explicitly have a dependency graph,
依赖图，这是否意味着有一些聪明的单遍算法可以用来实现这一点？但这非常酷。这个求和面积表在图像处理中被大量使用。它被用于像景深转换之类的事情。我正在写一个小的，一个小的 CUDA Python 例子，它将做一些古怪的，你知道，比如，它实际上会是一个例子，你可以给它一张图像，然后它会做一些图像转换。但是，但我对这在更高维度中看起来是什么样子也很好奇。我的意思是，如果我没记错的话，在 M 和 N 的依赖关系，它只是形成的矩形的和。对，对，对。在任何时间点。
especially when you get to multiple dimensions. And I thought that was very interesting. It sort of reminds me of some of the – there's some linear algebra algorithms that have a similar like dependency set. I think maybe like Jacobi kernels. But I haven't had a chance to really look into that part of it yet and whether that intuition that this is just a multidimensional scan and that it's got this more interesting
是的。但我猜如果你在做类似解耦回溯的事情，你可以到达那里。你可以通过查看不同的点到达那里。是的。是的。是的。它提出了有趣的调度问题，因为你希望你所有的依赖关系在扫描中都在你之前运行。在 1D 扫描中，这相当直接
dependency graph, does that mean that there's some clever single-pass algorithm that you can use to implement this? But it's very cool. And this summed area table, it gets used a lot in image processing. It gets used for things like depth of field transformations. I'm working on writing like a little, a little example in CUDA Python, that that's going to do some some quirky, you know, like, it'll actually like, be an example where you can give it an image, and then it'll do some image transformation. But, but I'm curious about what this looks like in higher dimensions, too. I mean, if I'm not mistaken, the dependency at M and N, it's just the sum of the rectangle formed. Right, right, right. At any point in time.
因为在今天的 GPU 上，它没有保证，但光栅化顺序，线程块执行的顺序，恰好是单调递增的。所以今天的 GPU 上，有这种隐式保证，即根本没有承诺，根本没有记录的行为，但恰好是这种情况，
Yeah. But I guess you could get there if you're doing like a decoupled look back kind of thing. You can get there by looking at different points. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And it presents interesting scheduling problems because you want all of your dependencies to be running before you in a scan. And in a 1D scan, that's pretty straightforward
如果线程块 N 正在运行，那么你知道线程块 0 到 N-1 已经运行完成或正在运行。但如果你确实为此构建了一个单遍多维算法，你需要更仔细地考虑光栅化顺序，因为我不知道如果你在做多维线程网格，那个隐式保证是否有效。但如果你线性化线程网格，这通常会发生，即使你在做多维的事情，所以即使你在启动一个在多维数据上工作的 CUDA 内核，
because on GPUs today, it's not guaranteed, but the rasterization order, the order in which thread blocks are executed, happens to be monotonically increasing. So on GPUs today, there's this implicit guarantee, which is that not at all promised, not at all documented behavior, but it happens to be the case that
有时你会因为各种原因以 1D 线程网格启动它，通常是因为你在做类似行向或列向的事情。但你必须小心这个多维扫描，以确保你有这种单调的进展，为了性能，至少你会想要确保你所有的依赖关系在你开始运行之前已经开始运行。是的。这里的 BQN 解决方案，我认为相当优雅，因为你或多或少做了我描述的那种事情，你做了两次扫描，然后你在那里做了转置。注意我已经添加了第二个解决方案，它——它是讽刺的吗？我不确定它是否讽刺，但很有趣的是，我首先用
if thread block N is running, then you know that thread blocks 0 to N-1 have either run to completion or are currently running. But if you did build a single pass multidimensional algorithm for this, you would need to think a little bit more carefully about rasterization order because I don't know if that implicit guarantee works if you're doing a multidimensional thread grid. But if you linearize the thread grid, which often happens even when you're doing multidimensional stuff, so even when you're launching a CUDA kernel that works on multidimensional data,
under transpose 得到了第一个，那只是因为我真的爱上了 BQN 中的 under 修饰符，under 是做什么的？所以 under 应用一个转换，然后做一些操作，然后基本上取消应用那个原始转换。好的，所以就像转置它，做这个事情，然后取消转置……所以使用它的经典方式是如果你想做一个反向扫描，你做加法扫描 under reverse，然后如果我给它五个数字，所以这是数字 0 到 4，0 1 2 3 4，然后如果我只是做一个加法扫描，我得到 0 1 3 6 10，但如果我想做一个反向扫描，我要么必须添加一些其他修饰符或高阶函数，这就是他们在函数式语言中所做的。比如 Haskell 有 scan L 和 scan R，一个从左边，一个从右边。
sometimes you'll end up launching it with a 1D thread grid for a variety of reasons, like usually because you're doing something like row-wise or column-wise. But you'd have to be careful with this multidimensional scan to ensure that you have this monotonic progress that for performance, at the very least, you'd want to ensure that all of your dependencies have started running before you've started running. Yeah. The BQN solution here is, I think, quite elegant because you did more or less the sort of thing that I described where you did the two scans and then you did the transpose there. Note that I've added a second solution which it's it's is it ironic i'm not sure if it's ironic but it's funny that i came to the first one with the with the
但我们有 under，所以我们只是写 under reverse。它反转它，做加法扫描，然后重新反转它。所以它基本上从后面做加法扫描。我们在 C++ 中也用反向迭代器处理这个问题，对吧？如果你想做一个反向扫描，你只是，你使用不同类型的迭代器。但像这个 under 适用于一吨不同的东西。我真正
under transpose first and that's just because i've been really falling in love with the under modifier in bqn and what what does under do so under applies a transformation, then does some operation, and then basically unapplies that original transformation. Okay, so it's like transpose it, do this thing, and then untrans... So the classic way to use this is if you want to do a reverse scan, you do a plus scan under reverse and then if i i give it five numbers so this is the number zero to four zero one two three four and then if i if i if i just do a plus scan i get zero one three six ten but if i want to do a reverse scan i either have to add some other modifier or higher order function which is what they do in functional languages. Like Haskell has scan L and scan R, one from the left, one from the right.
最近爱上的是使用它基本上修改某些部分，比如过滤掉。所以假设我有我的数组，让我们这样做，一个 5 个 1 的数组。如果我想给我的数组的某个子集加 1，你该怎么做？你知道，你可以做某种分散收集的事情，就像，嗯，我收集元素。
But we have under, so we just go under reverse. That reverses it, does a plus scan, and then re-reverses it. So it basically does a plus scan from the back. And we also deal with this in C++ with reverse iterators, right? If you want to do a reverse scan, you just, you use a different type of iterator. But like this under applies to a ton of different things. The one that I've really
或者像一个过滤器。一个过滤器，但然后你需要重建原始的，对吧？是的。所以这做起来不是一件简单的事情。而且像在函数式语言中，你甚至没有突变，
fallen in love with recently is using it to basically modify certain parts, like filter out. So say I've got my array, let's just do this, an array of five ones. If I want to add one to like a certain subset of my array, how do you do that? You know, you could do some scatter gather kind of thing where it's like, well, I gather the elements.
你最终可能不得不根据这些值拆分你的数组，突变你想要的值，然后重建它。然后重建，是的。Under 使你能够应用任何种类的过滤、压缩、选择。所以这是说获取第一个和第三个索引，然后应用
Or like a filter. A filter, but then you need to reconstruct the original, right? Yeah. So like it's a non-trivial thing to do. And like in functional languages where you don't even have mutation,
这个一元操作到你检索到的索引或值，然后像取消应用你的选择，所以就像任何时候你使用 oh，这就像，它只是美妙，这非常迷人，所以就像，所以它基本上就像你在这里使用它的方式，就像说，给我一个我可以原地修改的东西的视图。哦，那太酷了。而且总的来说，我使用过带有 reverse 和 transpose 的 unders
you might end up having to kind of like split your array based on these values, mutate the values you want to and then reconstruct it. And then reconstruct, yeah. Under enables you to apply any kind of filtering, compaction, selection. So this is saying get the first and third index and then apply
和类似这样的东西，但只有在过去几周做 Advent of Code 以来，我才真正发现这是一个超级常见的模式，你想要么构建一个索引列表，要么构建一个压缩掩码，一个过滤掩码，然后获得那个对你数据的视图，应用一些转换或用一些值替换它。这是一个非常地道的做法。而且它非常棒。抱歉，
this unary operation to the indexes or the values that you've retrieved and then like unapply your selection so just like anytime you're using oh which is like it's just beautiful that's very fascinating and so like so it's basically like what you're using it for here is like saying like give me a view of this thing that I can modify in place. Oh, that's super cool. And just in general, I have used unders with reverse and transpose
你本来要问一个后续问题。是的，是的。我要说的是，所以告诉我你对求和面积表的第二个解决方案，它不使用转置。好的。所以第一个使用 under transpose。第二个，基本上，它只是一个行向扫描。所以这是 cells 修饰符，对于矩阵，它将你的操作转换为在行而不是列上操作。
and things like this, but only since doing Advent of Code over the last couple of weeks have I really discovered that it's a super common pattern that you want to either build up a list of indexes or build up a compaction mask, a filtering mask, and then get that view into your data, apply some transformation or replace it with some value. And it's a very idiomatic thing to do. And it's incredibly nice. Sorry,
所以默认情况下，一个加号，所以如果我们摆脱这个，加法扫描是在列上的。如果我们加回加法扫描，使用 cells 修饰符。对于矩阵，这说，做这个行向，这对于一堆语言……你说它叫 cells？它叫 cells，是的。说。我不知道。也许只是通过你对 BQN 的潜在接触一直在影响我。但这是我第一次看到你向我展示 BQN 代码，我直觉上很容易就能看出它在做什么。它立刻就点击了。在你的解释中，我没有在任何一点迷路。通常我需要更多的脑力来理解它在做什么。
you were going to ask a follow-up question though. Yeah, yeah. I was going to say, so tell me about the second solution that you have to the summed area table, which does not use the transpose. Right. So the first one uses under transpose. The second one, basically, it's just a row-wise scan. So this is the cells modifier, which for a matrix converts your operation to operate on rows instead of columns.
非常酷。BQN 几年来一直是我最喜欢的语言。虽然我玩过 Jell-O 和 Wiwa，它们正在成为第一，但在过去几周从 Advent of Co.，以及过去半年更认真地使用它之后，它与其他语言拉开了差距。我意识到在所有语言中都非常繁琐的事情太多了，除了数组语言，一旦你在做类似网格或地图的事情，你有
So by default, a plus, so if we get rid of this, the plus scan is on the columns. And if we add back the plus scan, use the cells modifier. For a matrix, this says, do this row-wise, which for a bunch of languages... You said it's called cells? It's called cells, yeah. say. I don't know. Maybe it's just that latent exposure to BQN through you has been rubbing off on me. But this is one of the first times that you've shown me BQN code where I sort of intuitively can very easily tell what it's doing. And it just clicked very immediately. At no point in your explanation did I get lost. And usually it takes me a little bit more mental energy to understand what it's doing.
坐标，并且你正在检查你是否在某些地图的边界内或边界外，像所有这些图遍历，它只是非常非常直观，你可以给一个位置添加一个增量，你可以给一个位置添加一个增量列表以便四处移动，像所有这些在普通语言中，你必须手动调整你的 x 和 y 坐标，并手动检查每一个是否在网格之外，这只是……我得想办法让这个，你知道，我需要被付钱写 BQN，这就是我基本上试图弄清楚如何做的事情。好吧，你知道，你提到这一点很有趣，因为在未来的一集中，我……因为我一直在做 Python，我一直在做的这个特定项目，我一直在……
Very cool. BQN has been my favorite language for a couple years now. Although I've played around with Jell-O and Wiwa as becoming number one, but having used it more seriously over the last couple weeks from Advent of Co., but also just the last half year, it is the gap that it has put on other languages. There are just so many things that I've realized are incredibly cumbersome in all languages except for array languages like as soon as you're doing something with a grid or a map where you have
太酷了。BQN 几年来一直是我最喜欢的语言。虽然我曾尝试过 Jell-O 和 Wiwa，想让它们成为我的首选，但在过去几周通过 Advent of Code 以及过去半年的深入使用后，我发现它与其他语言之间存在巨大的差距。我意识到，除了数组语言之外，在所有其他语言中，处理网格或地图等任务都极其繁琐，尤其是当你需要
coordinates and like you're checking whether you're going in or outside the bounds of some maps like all these graph traversals and it's just so so intuitive like you can add a delta to a position and you can add a list of deltas to a position in order to move around and like all of that in a in a normal language you have to manually adjust your x and y coordinates and manually check each whether each one is outside of the grid and it's just uh i gotta figure out a way to to make this you know i you know i need to get paid to write bqn is what i'm trying to figure out how to do basically well you know it's funny you mention that because uh in a in a future episode uh i so i i because i've been working on python and uh this one particular project i've been working on i've been uh i
处理坐标，或者检查是否越界时，比如进行各种图遍历，它都非常直观。你可以将增量加到位置上，也可以将一系列增量加到位置上以进行移动。而在普通语言中，你必须手动调整 x 和 y 坐标，并手动检查每一个坐标是否超出了网格范围。我得想办法靠写 BQN 赚钱，这就是我基本上想弄明白的事情。有趣的是，你提到了这一点，因为在未来的一期节目中，我一直在使用 Python，而在我正在做的这个特定项目中，我一直在
finally at seven years at n, I finally had to learn something about machine learning kernels. And there's actually, like, some of the algorithms are pretty cool and intuitive once you get them. And I was just thinking as you were showing me this, like, oh, it would be really cool to implement, like, Flash Attention
在英伟达工作了七年之后，我终于不得不去学习一些关于机器学习内核的知识了。实际上，一旦你理解了其中的一些算法，它们确实非常酷且直观。当你向我展示这些时，我一直在想，如果能用 Flash Attention 实现这些功能一定会很酷。
and BQN. And I want to show you at some point some of these other machine learning like layers and algorithms like uh uh you know softmax is pretty cool um uh algorithmically but like even like flash attention i was literally just thinking like i don't know what the formula or the algorithm is for flash attention we'll save save it for another episode. But like, I did look into doing some machine learning stuff in BQN or APL one time.
还有 BQN。我想在某个时候向你展示一些其他的机器学习层和算法，比如 Softmax，从算法角度来看它非常酷。但即使是像 Flash Attention 这样的东西，我刚才也在想，我不知道它的公式或算法是什么，我们留到下一集再说吧。不过，我确实曾经研究过在 BQN 或 APL 中做一些机器学习的事情。
And I was just like, and literally I was thinking about Softmax because Softmax is like, it's ridiculous. Like it's two operations, one after the other. It's like, it's like- Yeah, it's so simple. Yeah, they make it sound- Yeah.
我当时就在想 Softmax，因为它太荒谬了。它就是两个操作，一个接一个。就像是——是的，太简单了。是的，他们把它说得——是的。
Yeah. It's like a division with a floor or something. I can't remember the two operations, but it's like, this is nothing. This doesn't need a name. And relu is like the same thing. Like a lot of these terms are just like composed binary operations,
是的。就像是一个带取整的除法之类的。我不记得那两个操作是什么了，但感觉这根本不算什么，不需要专门起个名字。ReLU 也是一样。很多这些术语其实就是组合的二元运算，
which is literally like two symbols. And like, so the APL version, it's like a couple lines of code. Have you heard of like llm.c, which is like a simple implementation of GPT-2? Yeah, yeah. Didn't we do a refactoring of that into CUDA? And we, I'm not sure if there's a link online to that,
字面上就是两个符号。所以 APL 版本只需要几行代码。你听说过 llm.c 吗？那是一个 GPT-2 的简单实现。是的，是的。我们不是把它重构成了 CUDA 吗？我不确定网上有没有相关的链接，
but well, if there is, we'll find it. I think – I bet you could write, like, LM.C and BQN and, like, have it fit on, like, you know, a slide. Probably, minus the, you know, GPU acceleration. Yeah, yeah, but that's – I i mean when you have it expressed in a real an array language i feel like it's it's pretty straightforward to figure out how do you lower it to a gpu yeah maybe yeah but uh but yeah i i bet it i bet it would i bet it would be very elegant i bet it'd be very elegant yeah oh you have me excited about pqn what are you doing to me yeah well there's a paper out there called convolutional neural networks and apl that was published at a workshop a couple years ago link in the show notes if folks
但如果有的话，我们会找到的。我想——我敢打赌你可以用 BQN 写出 LM.C，并且让它能写在一张幻灯片上。当然，不包括 GPU 加速的部分。是的，是的，但那是——我的意思是，当你用真正的数组语言来表达时，我觉得弄清楚如何将其降级到 GPU 是非常直接的。也许吧，但我觉得它会非常优雅。噢，你让我对 BQN 感到兴奋了，你对我做了什么？好吧，有一篇名为《卷积神经网络与 APL》的论文，是几年前在一个研讨会上发表的，如果大家感兴趣，可以在节目说明中找到链接。
are interested uh so there has been some exploration of this stuff anyways it's funny because you know i've been we i've been in video for seven years and i mostly have worked on like the compute hbc stuff and uh i think i think some people who areVIDIA who don't work on, like, the AI stuff, like, to some degree, I wouldn't say there's resentment. But you sometimes have this feeling as, like, ugh, like, the stuff I work, like, this other thing gets all the attention. And the stuff that I'm really passionate about, you know, which is just, like, general compute, doesn't get as much attention. And it can get to some people. And this is the first time in my time at NVIDIA when I've i've like really had to look into machine learning kernels they're actually pretty cool they got some interesting algorithms in them um and uh and uh i just like i'm seeing out in six
所以人们已经对这些东西进行了一些探索。无论如何，这很有趣，因为我在英伟达工作了七年，主要从事计算和高性能计算（HPC）方面的工作。我认为英伟达里一些不做人工智能相关工作的人，在某种程度上，我不会说是有怨恨，但有时你会有一种感觉，比如，唉，我做的东西，而另一件事却得到了所有的关注。而我真正热衷的东西，也就是通用计算，却没有得到那么多的关注。这可能会影响到一些人。这是我在英伟达期间第一次真正需要研究机器学习内核，它们实际上非常酷，里面有一些有趣的算法。而且我还要再待六个月，
months and and uh uh i hope my entire world does not become consumed by writing machine learning kernels. But I don't know. Maybe I'll have fun with it. We'll see. I mean, if we're all out of work in 10 years, I'm just going to write BQN programs full time for fun. I know what my hobby will be if the AI takes over the world. But we're still a ways away from that, I think. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
我希望我的整个世界不会被编写机器学习内核所占据。但我不知道，也许我会乐在其中。我们走着瞧。我的意思是，如果 10 年后我们都失业了，我就全职写 BQN 程序来消遣。我知道如果人工智能接管了世界，我的爱好会是什么。但我认为我们离那一天还很远。请务必在你的播客应用中或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com 查看节目说明，获取我们今天提到的所有内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论的链接，
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。我们的口号是充满信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。